“Conocemos el ciclo en Francia: en el nombre
de los “valores superiores” tenemos una
comunidad (islámica) que está en el punto
de mira todo el tiempo…”
Este hombre que veis en pantalla es OMAR SULEIMAN,
uno de los imanes más influyentes de Estados
Unidos. En este vídeo dice que Francia es
el epicentro de la islamofobia en Europa.
Acusa a Macrón y a todas las instituciones
francesas de hostigar a las comunidades musulmanas.
Según este hombre, Francia es el laboratorio
de pruebas de todas las políticas para oprimir
a los islámicos.
“En ningún lugar como Francia se cristaliza
mejor estas políticas que crean un aterrador
marco del que debemos tener cuidado”
Mientras tanto, Erdogan, en Turquía, ha llegado
a proponer un boicot contra los productos
franceses. Y algo parecido ha dicho el presidente
de Pakistán.
¿Por qué, de repente, tantos líderes islámicos
odian a Francia? La razón es lo que el propio
presidente francés, Emmanuel Macrón, llama
la lucha contra el separatismo islámico.
A estas alturas, parece evidente que Francia
tiene un problema con el Islam radical. Y
Macron ha dejado claro que el problema no
es el Islam en sí, sino el radicalismo.
Sin embargo ¿Por qué hay tantos líderes
islámicos que se dan por aludidos? ¿Qué
problema tiene Francia con el Islam radical?
En este vídeo, te lo vamos a explicar.
El 16 de octubre de 2016, un profesor de un
Instituto Francés, SAMUEL PATY, fue decapitado
por uno de sus alumnos. El asesino era un
chico de 18 años que se había ofendido cuando
su profesor mostró unas caricaturas de Mahoma
en clase para hacer un debate sobre la libertad
de expresión.
Para que os hagáis una idea, desde el año
2015, los terroristas islámicos han asesinado
a 250 personas. Eso incluye a los propios
autores de esas caricaturas de Mahoma. Claramente,
Francia tiene un problema con el Islam radical.
Y no, esto no es algo que preocupe únicamente
a la extrema derecha. El 89% de los franceses,
de todas las ideologías, consideran que el
terrorismo islámico es uno de los problemas
más terribles a los que se enfrenta el país.
¡Ojo! Esto no significa que todos los musulmanes
sean terroristas ni mucho menos. Ni siquiera
que todos los que estén pidiendo boicots
contra Francia lo sean. SIn ir más lejos,
el señor que salía al principio de este
vídeo está amenazado de muerte por el DAESH.
Para que os hagáis una idea, otros países
como Alemania o Países Bajos también tienen
grandes comunidades musulmanas: pero los casos
de Francia y Bélgica son especialmente graves
¡Pensad que no sólo hablamos de atentados
terroristas! Ciudades como París o Marsella
tienen barrios enteros donde sólo se atreve
a entrar la policía. En algunos casos, podríamos
hablar de todo un Estado paralelo en el seno
de la sociedad francesa. Comunidades radicalizadas,
profesores que no se atreven a hablar libremente
en los colegios públicos y mujeres que no
pueden vestir como quieran cuando salen por
la calle. La decapitación de Samuel Paty
ha sido la gota que ha colmado el vaso. Y
el presidente MACRON ha dicho ¡Basta!
Macron lanza una campaña contra el “separatismo
islámico” en las comunidades musulmanas
Este anuncio ha desatado una oleada de odio
anti francés en todo el mundo musulmán.
Los países del golfo están organizando boycots
contra los productos franceses. El presidente
de Turquía y el de Pakistán han pedido a
sus ciudadanos que eviten comprar productos
franceses. Algunos líderes religiosos comparan
a Macrón con Hitler o Narendra Modi ¡Y ya
sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos! La comparación
no tiene ningún sentido. Francia ha dicho
que quiere acabar con el Islam radical, es
decir, contra el terrorismo islámico: no
contra toda la religión islámica. Nadie
ha hablado de cerrar todas las mezquitas,
ni de deportar a todos los musulmanes, ni
nada parecido. Sin embargo, la pregunta, la
auténtica pregunta es... ¿Por qué Francia
tiene más problemas con el radicalismo islámico
que Alemania?
¿Qué quiere hacer Macron para solucionarlo?
¿Y por qué tantos líderes islámicos se
han puesto en su contra? Hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes, vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
EL HIJO DE PIERRE SE LLAMA AKHMED
Los años 50 y 60 fueron la época dorada
de Francia ¿Y qué pasa cuando la economía
de un país crece como la espuma? Pues que
de repente, las empresas reciben a los inmigrantes
con los brazos abiertos ¿Y de dónde venían
los inmigrantes franceses? Pues de las colonias
francesas del Norte de África. Países como
Argelia o Túnez enviaban a millones de hombres
a trabajar a las fábricas de Renault o Tefal.
Hablamos de gente que hablaba francés como
lengua materna, se llamaban PIERRE o JEAN-MARIE,
y se casaban con mujeres francesas. En otras
palabras: se integraban al completo.
¡Sin embargo todo cambió en el año 1973!
The oil producers countries of the Muslim
world decided to use their oil as a political
weapon
Exacto, 1973 es el año de la crisis del petróleo.
Una crisis que azotó especialmente a Francia.
El paro subió y todas esas empresas que recibían
a los inmigrantes con los brazos abiertos...
empezaron a despedir a gente. Poco a poco,
los inmigrantes dejaron de llegar a Francia.
Y entonces, es cuando el Gobierno Francés
sacó esta ley, que parece muy razonable pero
que tuvo una consecuencias muy importantes.
En el año 1978, Francia aprobó la ley de
reunificación familiar. Esta ley permitía
que los inmigrantes franceses, recién nacionalizados,
se trajeran a su familia de sus países de
origen. Esto llevó a una nueva oleada de
inmigrantes. También venían de países como
Francia, Argelia o Marruecos. Pero ya no eran
hombres en edad de trabajar sino sus familiares.
Por supuesto, esta política tiene toda la
lógica del mundo... Y diréis ¿Pero qué
tiene que ver todo esto con el radicalismo
islámico? Pues tiene una influencia importante.
Pensadlo bien: antes, los inmigrantes que
llegaban no tenían más remedio que integrarse
en el país: hacer amigos, pareja y vida francesa.
Sin embargo, a partir de los años 70, estos
inmigrantes ya podían casarse con mujeres
argelinas, que se quedaban en casa y cuidaban
de los hijos. Cada vez había menos matrimonios
mixtos. Y los hijos de estos inmigrantes que
se llamaban PIERRE o JEAN-MARIE se llamaban
AKHMED y HASSAN ¡Por supuesto! Esto no tiene
por qué tener ningún problema. Cada uno
puede llamarse como quiere. Pero sí nos sirve
de indicador de cómo esos argelinos de segunda
generación empezaban a tener su propia cultura,
distinta del resto de la sociedad francesa.
Esto explica que los primeros debates sobre
el uso del HIYAB en lugares públicos no se
dieran en los años 60 sino en 1989 ¡Pero
esperad un momento! Porque, hasta la fecha,
Francia todavía no tenía un problema con
el radicalismo islámico. El problema comienza
a finales de los años 90 ¿Qué pasa en esos
momentos? A partir de ese momento es cuando
Francia empieza a perder competitividad frente
al mercado global. Os lo explicamos aquí,
en VisualPolitik, en un vídeo de hace varios
años que os dejo en la descripción. Desde
el año 2000, las exportaciones netas de Francia
no han dejado de crecer. Mientras Alemania
se ha convertido en toda una potencia industrial
global, Francia lleva en declive económico
durante todo el siglo 21.
¿Conclusión? París, que es la ciudad más
rica de Francia, tiene un paro estructural
del 8%. El paro juvenil ha llegado al 19%
¿Y a que no adivináis quién es el grupo
más afectado por este paro? ¡Exacto! Los
descendientes de estos inmigrantes argelinos.
Pierre y Jean-Marie encontraron trabajo en
Renault pero sus hijos y sus nietos, Akhmed
y Hassan están en el paro ¡Pero aquí no
termina el drama! ¿Recordáis que os decía
que Francia tiene regulaciones estrictas en
todos los mercados? Pues eso también afecta
al mercado de los alquileres. Si alguno de
vosotros ha vivido en París lo sabe bien:
es casi imposible encontrar un piso en esta
ciudad. Incluso los trabajadores bien pagados,
que llegan a la ciudad contratados por una
multinacional, terminan en casas viejas, pequeñas
y tremendamente caras. Según EXPATISTAN.COM,
alquilar un piso de 45m2 en un barrio normal
de Paris cuesta unos 1200 euros al mes. Es
el mismo precio que en una ciudad como Munich.
La diferencia es que París tiene un paro
del 8% y Munich un paro del 2%. Si esos expats
que trabajan en multinacionales se quejan
de la vivienda, imaginad a nuestros amigos
Akhmed y Hassan, que están en el paro ¿Conclusión?
Bienvenido a tu nueva casa en los Barrios
Marginales de París. Cerca de la estación
de metro de Stalingrado puedes encontrar tu
propia vivienda a coste 0! Maravillosos parques
con los mejores narcotraficantes de la ciudad,
fallas urbanas y las mejores mezquitas salafistas
patrocinadas por nuestros amigos de Arabia
Saudita ¡Te espera una nueva vida en tu barrio
marginal!
¿Y qué pasa dentro de esos barrios marginales?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LA SEDUCCIÓN DEL RADICALISMO
Muchos pensaríais que el Islam radical es
una vuelta a la edad media: una ideología
ultraconservadora y ultrareligiosa ¿Verdad?
¡Error! ¡Craso error! La ideología que
profesan la mayor parte de los radicales islámicos
en Francia es el SALAFISMO. El Salafismo nació
en el s. XVIII en lo que ahora es Arabia Saudita.
Pero fue en los años 60 del siglo XX cuando
se convirtió en el movimiento religioso mayoritario
en este país. Por esos momentos, Arabia Saudita
ya se había convertido en la petromonarquía
que es ahora. Desde entonces, el dinero del
zumo de dinosaurio ha financiado la construcción
de mezquitas y escuelas islámicas por todo
el mundo. Esto explica que el salafismo esté
ganando terreno a el resto de confesiones
islámicas. Por ejemplo ¿Recordáis al profesor
asesinado? Pues su asesino venia de Chechenia.
Tradicionalmente, la religión mayoritaria
en Chechenia era el Islam sufi. Sin embargo,
en los últimos años, el salafismo ha ido
ganando terreno. Y algo parecido ocurre en
Francia. En el año 2004 ya había más de
5000 salafistas en el país.
Estos salafistas estaban concentrados, principalmente,
en los barrios marginales. Y esto explica
noticias como esta.
Los revueltas de inmigrantes incendian Francia
por la novena noche consecutiva
¡Exacto! En el año 2005, Francia sufrió
unas revueltas que se prolongaron por 3 semanas.
2 civiles asesinados y 8000 coches incendiados.
Y en ese momento es cuando Francia se dio
cuenta de que tenía un problema ¿Y cuál
diríais que fue la solución? Pues atentos.
El Consejo Francés para la fé musulmana
crea un consejo teológico para frenar el
discurso radical
Exacto, para frenar el avanza del Islam radical,
Francia creó un órgano gubernamental para
comunicarse con la comunidad musulmana. La
idea era promover una versión del Islam compatible
con la democracia. Aunque algunos críticos
dirían que más bien, lo que Francia intentaba
era diseñar su propia versión del Islam.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Ha funcionado este consejo?
Pues juzgad por vosotros mismos: en 2005,
Francia tenía alrededor de 5000 salafistas.
En 2010, eran más de 12.000 y a día de hoy
se habla de entre 30.000 y 50.000. Eso por
no hablar de todos los atentados terroristas
que han asolado este país desde entonces.
Y diréis: vale ¿Entonces cuál es la solución?
Pues lo cierto es que, a día de hoy, se sabe
muy poco sobre cómo evitar la radicalización.
Si hay algo controvertido en este mundo, es
la política anti terrorista. Hay toda clase
de soluciones sobre la mesa. En Arabia Saudita
han creado “centros de desradicalización”
que imitan los métodos para rehabilitar a
los drogadictos. Los terroristas hacen cosas
como arte terapia, dinámicos de grupos y
cosas parecidas ¿Resultado? Según el Gobierno
saudí, es un éxito. Pero la realidad es
que ya hay más de 50 casos de personas supuestamente
desdadicalizadas que han vuelto a cometer
atentados. En algunas universidades de España
y de California han llegado a hacer escáneres
cerebrales de terroristas para entender qué
tipo de mensajes podrían servir para desradicalizar
a un potencial terrorista. El tema de la radicalizacion
y la desradicalización es tan complejo que
daría para un vídeo en sí mismo. Así que
vamos a limitarnos a contar lo que ha propuesto
Emmanuel Macron.
LA CRUZADA CONTRA EL SEPARATISMO ISLÁMICO
A estas alturas, podemos decir que uno de
los principales factores del radicalismo son
las mezquitas radicales. Y la mayor parte
de esas mezquitas están pagadas con dinero
que viene del extranjero. Sin embargo, si
buscáis en Google, apenas encontraréis un
registro concreto de quién ha pagado qué
¿Por qué? Pues porque, a diferencia de las
empresas, las religiones no tienen que publicar
sus libros de cuentas en ningún sitio. Al
igual que las ONGs, las organizaciones religiosas
están exentas de pagar impuestos. Así que
los inspectores de Hacienda no las investigan.
A eso, hay que sumarle otro factor: el salafismo
no es una religión jerárquica. A diferencia
del catolicismo, no existe un Papa del salafismo
ni nada que se le parezca. Es más, cuando
decimos que Arabia Saudita ha financiado la
construcción de una mezquita, no nos referimos
al GOBIERNO de este país. En la mayor parte
de los casos son grupos privados. Pensadlo
bien: basta con que un grupo de millonarios
saudíes hagan una transferencia a unos voluntarios
en Francia para que se pueda construir una
mezquita. Conclusión: es casi imposible saber
dónde se está promoviendo el radicalismo.
Y por eso, el plan de Macron consiste en hacer
un registro nacional con todos los lugares
de culto islámico. Saber de dónde viene
la financiación y qué tipo de ideas promueven
los clérigos. Además, Macron también quiere
prohibir el home schooling. De esta forma,
garantiza que todos los niños y niñas francesas
reciben la misma educación. Y esto es lo
que ha generado las críticas de líderes
como el Presidente de Turquía.
Erdogan dice que los musulmanes en Europa
están siendo tratados como los judíos antes
de la II Guerra Mundial
Si lleváis tiempo suscritos a VisualPolitik,
ya sabéis que la gran aspiración de Erdogan
es ampliar su cuota de influencia en todo
el mundo islámico. Este tipo de declaraciones
van en ese línea. Creo que no hace falta
decir que la comparación es completamente
absurda. Pero lo cierto es que Erdogan no
ha sido el único líder en criticar el plan
de Macron. Atentos a lo que ha dicho el Presidente
de Pakistán.
Imran Khan pide a los países musulmanes que
confronten colectivamente la tendencia de
islamofobia en los países europeos
Concretamente, en el discurso que dio el presidente
de Pakistán, las caricaturas de Mahoma son
discurso del odio. Es decir, según este hombre,
la libertad de expresión no contempla la
blasfemia. Es comprensible que piense así:
en Pakistan llevan varios años sin saber
lo que es la libertad de expresión. Sin ir
más lejos, este vídeo no se podría ver
desde Pakistán porque YouTube está prohibido
en todo el país. Lo mismo ocurre con TikTok
y todas las páginas de NoPor ¡Pero esperad
un momento! Porque ya me puedo imaginar lo
que pensará alguno: esto es una guerra entre
los valores Occidentales y los valores islámicos.
Sin embargo, conviene recordar que muchos
líderes occidentales estarían de acuerdo
con mucho de lo que ha dicho el presidente
de Pakistán. Atentos a lo que dijo el Papa
Francisco días después de los atentados
de Charlie Hebdo.
“No se puede provocar, no se puede insultar
a otras creencias de la gente, uno no puede
burlarse de la gente, uno no puede burlarse
de la fe. Si el doctor Gasparri, mi gran amigo,
dice una mala palabra contra mi madre... ¡Le
espera un puñetazo!”
Llegados a este punto, creo que es importante
dejar clara una cosa: la libertad de expresión
SI contempla la blasfemia, la sátira y los
insultos contra una religión. Ahí está
el caso de Slayer, Marilyn Manson o Behemoth:
artistas que han hecho toda una carrera basándose
en la blasfemia. Todos hemos visto películas
como “La Vida de Brian” o series de Televisión
que hacen sátiras religiosas. Todo eso está,
o debería estar perfectamente contemplado
por la libertad de expresión. Nadie debería
tener miedo de que les vayan a matar por criticar
o hacer sátira de una religión o una idea
política.
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque el hecho
de que Erdogan o Imran Khan se equivoquen
no significa que el plan de Macron sea perfecto.
En realidad, hay muchas críticas legítimas
que se pueden hacer a este registro de mezquitas
que quiere hacer Francia. Y por eso, ahora
vamos a abrir debate: ¿Os parece bien que
el estado regule las religiones? ¿Creéis
que el plan de Macrón va a solucionar el
problema del separatismo islámico? Podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas, así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto.